oh I got a whole lot to talk about when
is the beauty line coming soon berry
30b is only getting bigger and busier
[Music]
only ET is with her machine on her Vegas
residency the inspiration behind her new
album and oh yeah her acting debut in
hustler
[Music]
how did that come about - JLo call you
did you call her well she called me when
she first spoke to my team and I she
really wanted me to do like this I think
like the second lead role and due to the
fact that I gotta work on my album I got
like a little smaller role but I had to
be in this movie like this movie is
something that I could relate all the
actress in the movie I could sell them
like no no no this is how it goes mhmmm
because you know like the club that the
movie is based on that's the type of
clubs that I work this was my life how
is it working with JLo in this capacity
well I haven't been on set yet but I
worked with her before right and the
music videos in arrow and she's just so
caring I could say do you need this do
you need that like what do you need do
you want
are we gonna get another collaboration
for this movie you in jail oh I don't
know maybe so sometimes artists when
things are done is they hey what are you
doing yeah let's go to the studio you
never know what can you say about your
character what can you teach you'll get
all your get all the NATO how are you
feeling about stardom is it everything
that you thought it was gonna be is
harder better it's definitely harder
like the more money the more problems
the more people there that things they
know you and the opinions it just gets
harder people don't understand some
people don't understand the the struggle
some people don't understand the work
that I put in so they will just always
try to think that it came easy for me
and it's just like you know it's
something that I never thought it would
be like I totally understand the
meltdowns that we started to be having
why they'd be shaving their heads why
they go through what they go through
because this is crazy you feel for
Britney though then yes what she said I
went through yeah it's a hard life but
you wanna know something was like I'm a
Duggar time already famous I got no
choice but to keep it going and she's
got a lot going how was your life right
now really like influencing your next
album you want to know what's so funny
it's so crazy because like when it comes
to my my next album and everything I
always do think like it's like well I
can't really rap about the struggle I
can't really rap about what I used to
work on because you know how to pass the
next level so what am I gonna talk about
besides the glamour when I feel like
I've been in a lot of drama I feel like
people have thrown so many things so
many different crazy obstacles a new
chapter in my life that is just I all
got a whole lot of talk about the diet
things are we saying that it's like you
know what every so much time that I say
it people eat me up but life for me they
say I complained so much that you know
what I'm still putting my music
then anyone that you want to collaborate
with I feel like a Beyonce collaboration
of course so don't walk back you don't
say you'd be down for it
the but nothing in this world I like
more - checked your Vegas residency yeah
what is going on with that are you gonna
announce more date soon how is it
performing in Vegas well the first time
I was a little nervous because you know
like it's like I never did it before and
I wonder how the residency is gonna go
and it was amazing
and yeah we're just gonna have dates
every month and everything and I'm just
gonna turn up it's a big party night I'm
a cool person a party with a party with
but one thing she's not taking on
politics people really want you to run
for political office would you ever do
that no because that feel like that's a
big responsibility you know what I'm
saying like azuz like is not sometimes
like I feel like if I want to quit my
job today I could quit it like I'd be
like oh I don't care like that's it
whatever I'm setting up for me and my
daughter yeah but it's like when you are
like a political person this is like you
cannot let millions of people down there
voted for you they're rooting for you to
make their lives better so this is not
my thing
what do you see is the future of the
cardi B brand I see everything I feel
like I can't accomplish everything in
anything so it is like whatever that I
can't set my mind to do yeah I could do
it whatever it is that includes her
second fashion ova collection launching
May 8th
how is this one different than the first
well this one is different than the
first because we have more color and we
have more cutouts you know what I'm
saying it's more fun it's more
summertime yeah but it also have that
matrix look that I like these colors are
more like pastel colors blacks of course
like this is one of my collections is
this one your favorite pieces yes this
one of my favorite asses it's very
matrix and it's sexy but it's so classy
and clean and I love it